i am now a millionaire and i'll show you
exactly how i did it
[Music]
hi my name is jamie higgs and two years
ago this was the only house i owned i
met samuel leeds and he told me to
refinance it and invest the equity in
other properties that's exactly what i
did i joined the academy refinanced this
house and i invested it to buy further
properties i am now a millionaire and
i'll show you exactly how i did it one
of the things samuel told me to do was
to tell everybody what you do so i did i
bought a car i signed up my car now
everyone in newport knows i'm a property
investor
see you later
with the funds i raised from the
refinance of my house we bought this and
the flats above it's a whole commercial
and residential mix property so let me
show you the rest with 275 thousand
pound it came with six units in total
we split the titles which helped us save
on stamp duty and we also refurbed it
for 30 000 pounds the value of this
whole block now is 475 000 pounds which
is a 200 000 pound uplift so what are
they going to do with the profit from
this project
we're not going to sell it we're going
to refinance it because you don't pay
tax on debt
once we've refinanced it and we've
pulled all the profit out we're going to
move forward and buy more properties so
this was the next house we bought we
bought it from a motivated seller who
reached out to me on facebook she'd
probably seen the sign-written car
we paid a hundred thousand pounds for
this property she didn't even have time
to put a go with an estate agent so we
stepped in and helped right the property
is now worth a hundred and fifty
thousand pound we picked up the keys at
3 p.m and at 5 00 pm we handed it to our
new tenants
and this property this property we
bought using the buy refurbished
refinance rent model it's actually a
property we bought for my sister-in-law
she's our tenant when you understand how
to recycle your cash over and over again
you can buy properties like this
forever
i've used this strategy the buy
refurbished refinance rent strategy to
buy multiple properties all across the
south wales corridor which has made me a
millionaire so now i'm a millionaire do
i still live in this house the answer is
yes
i didn't go into property to buy great
big mansions and fancy cars i went into
property to support my two children and
create generational wealth so i did
build this porch it cost seven thousand
pounds it added twenty five thousand
pains worth of equity under the value of
the house samuel leeds teaches for every
pound you spend you add three pound on
that's exactly what i did and now i'm a
millionaire
i hope you enjoyed the video my name's
jamie higgs
of course all this wouldn't be possible
without my mentor samuel leeds samuel
thank you for making me a millionaire
well done jackie this guy is an absolute
beast what a legend killing it in
newport if you want to check out jamie's
full story of exactly how he's done this
from start to finish then check out his
full interview right up around here and
if you want to come to the property
millionaire intensive is it worth it
jamie 100 get down free tickets on the
house in the description i'll see you
there god bless and peace out